is China now cooperating with the United
States to figure out what happened and
what do you want from them now
well they said they're doing an
investigation that they're doing an
investigation so let's see what happens
with their investigation but we're doing
investigations also yeah go ahead please
every country has a responsibility to
tell the rest the world's going on
you've talked repeatedly about how this
could have been stopped in the past I
know you don't want to Telegraph what
you would do but do you think that there
should be some consequences if in the
end you know China was responsible for
all of this well if they were knowingly
responsible certainly if they did if it
was a mistake a mistake is a mistake but
if they were knowingly responsible yeah
then there should be consequences you're
talking about you know potentially lives
like nobody's seen since 1917 and you
know the other thing had we not done
what we did in terms of closing because
there is that concept of let's let it
ride but at some point I'm gonna have to
I don't want to embarrass countries that
I like and leaders that I like but you
have to see some of these numbers you
know in my opinion so we're talking
about maybe 60,000 or so that's a lot of
people but that's a hundred thousand was
the minimum we thought that we could get
to and we will be lower than that number
anywhere from one hundred to two hundred
and twenty thousand people but I really
believe it could have been millions of
people had we not done what we did we
made a lot of good decisions but one of
those things good I want to look at the
facts please
last week you claim that your charge of
everything yet the American people don't
understand why you're unwilling to use
the awesome powers of your presidency to
make American companies manufacture the
PPE and also the testing equipment that
you knew you implement the implement
your recommendation about who you are
how try with tmn recommendations for GM
and what has time immediate is what my
name is Doug Christian with talk media
news go ahead keep reading your question
the thing is how to make companies build
these testing equipment so that you can
do what you want more doing we're doing
it right now with ventilators we have
General Motors we have General Electric
we have 11 different companies great
companies building them for us all over
the United States we're starting to make
our own gowns as they call it we're
making some incredible things and as far
as the testing is concerned most of that
now is done in the United States we're
doing it in the United States our
different platforms and so I just don't
think you were listening or complaining
to which senators vice president which
senator today which independent angus
King okay angus King is worse than any
Democrat go ahead he was he was livid
actually he said that because he's a
he's a Democrat okay angus King is not
an independent he uses that term for
whatever reason it's a waste of time Oh
motive yes yes you haven't seen him okay
you haven't seen him know angus King is
a Democrat and that was totally staged I
heard that and it was totally staged
just like you read the question he read
his question yeah please in the back
ask you about one of your retweets that
you would one the one you retweeted from
Paul Sperry let's see if authorities
enforce the social distancing orders for
master Ramadan like they did churches
during Easter I'm wondering I would like
to see that and you know I just spoke
with leaders and people that love
mosques they love mosques and I'm all in
favor of that but I would say that there
could be a difference and we'll have to
see what will happen because I've seen a
great disparity in this country I've
seen a great disparity I mean I've seen
a very strong anti-israel bent in
Congress with Democrats it it was
unthinkable seven or eight or ten years
ago and now they're into a whole
different thing between Omar and AOC I
say AOC plus three add them on you have
I mean the things that they say about
Israel are so bad and I can't believe it
now just a minute so I would be
interested to see that because they go
after Christian churches but they don't
tend to go after mosques and I don't
want him to go after mosques but I do
want to see what their what their bent
is yes please in the back think I just
had a call with moms I just had a call
with ministers rabbis we had a
tremendous go with the faith leaders no
I don't think that at all I am somebody
that believes in faith and it matters
not what your faith is but our
politicians seem to treat different
faiths very differently and they seem to
think in I don't know what happened with
our country but the Christian faith is
treated much differently than it was and
I think it's treated very unfairly yes
please go ahead the back
[Music]
if the Paycheck protection program saved
an estimated 15 million jobs run out of
money the Democrat specific specifically
Nancy Pelosi have been blocking that
funding you know why speaker Pelosi is
dragging well she thinks it's politics I
don't think it's good politics Nancy
Pelosi has been blocking it Schumer has
been blocking it and I think they think
it's good politics I don't think it's
good politics I think it's bad politics
but I don't care about the politics it's
so great for our country because we're
going to have all of these companies
that are good you know it's a bigger
employer let's say it's the same but
essentially it's the same power all of
these small businesses added together as
the big companies it's about 50/50 and
it's so important and they will be
scattered if we weren't able to do what
we're doing and essentially we're giving
these small businesses that won't make
it they can't because they're closed
we're giving them money to take care of
their employees so when we open they can
get back into business it's been a very
popular plan even with Democrats I think
it basically passed unanimously twice
the first section which is 350 billion
so we're trying to get 250 Nancy Pelosi
is blocking it she sits in her house in
San Francisco overlooking the ocean and
she doesn't want to come back she
doesn't want to come back she doesn't
want to come back to DC she's got to get
back and get this thing approved it's
very important please
possibly weeks what goes through your
mind when you see pranks a girl probably
be chasing Florida it's not a concern
for when we stop saying some of these
restrictions being evicted well as I
described we go Metro by metro county by
county and so I'd have to link that with
a specific County and look at their case
rates I believe the governor and the
public health system that Florida has
they have some of the best County Public
Health individuals I have ever had to
deal with they are amazing that as I had
to work with them under hiv-aids so it
the health it the county health
directors believe that that's
appropriate for their County then I I'm
not gonna second judge an individual's
approach to this because every I can't
see into every single County and load
the low rates I can just see there's no
cases so I don't know if that's a County
with very small cases or not but I think
their county health efficient and many
of the counties as you know are really
free of this horrible enemy so we're
opening up you'll be seeing a lot of
this country start to open up fairly
quickly yes please you mentioned the
importance of social distancing but for
example Steven Moore so when you
appointed to your open the country task
force is organizing a protest in
Wisconsin but aren't they in a sense
protesting your very own guidelines well
we have a flexibility I didn't see what
Steven said I can tell you is a very
good economist he's been calling shots
right sorry he said we need to be the
Rosa Parks of government and justices
well there is a lot of injustice when
you look at Virginia where they want to
take your guns away if they want to
violate your Second Amendment when you
look at I mean look I'm getting along
very nicely with the governor of
Michigan but she has things don't buy
paint don't buy roses don't fly I mean
she's got all these crazy things I
really believe somebody sitting in their
boat in a lake should be okay they
shouldn't arrest people some of them are
being unreasonable I really believe that
they're being unreasonable
but I think Virginia is a great case
though because they're using this
they're trying to take your guns away in
Virginia and the people in Virginia
aren't aren't careful that's what's
going to happen to them so yeah I mean I
could see where he's coming from I think
it's a strong statement strong statement
because hopefully this will be over very
soon for all of us but some have gotten
carried away they have absolutely gotten
carried away purchasing your social
distancing guidelines I don't know I
mean I know this there are a lot of
protests out there and I just think that
some of the governors have gotten
carried away you know you have a lot of
people that don't have to be told to do
what they're doing they've been really
doing everything we've asked and we have
a few states where frankly I spoke to
the governor's and I could have gotten
him to do if I wanted to do what would
have been perhaps politically correct
but they've been doing incredibly anyway
and as one of them said everybody's
doing exactly the same in fact our
record is better than states where
they're under a mandate or you know
where they've agreed to do certain
things now we have some great states out
there we have incredible people in our
country and for the most part that it's
a strong statement but I understand
where it's coming from and I think one
of the Great's would be one of the
really important places that people
really have to start looking at is
what's going on in Virginia because
that's a mess with the government with
really a governor that's under siege
anyway yeah please know it would be with
a beautiful head of white hair go ahead
I'll tell you if I like is here in about
a minute after he asked the question
does the tweeting about in the face of
Virginia and linking the Second
Amendment to some of these issues about
lifting some of these restrictions in
these states not thanks opposed to
concern for the governors and civil
unrest and potentially notes
faces I have a second question for you
well I think just for that question I
think that's an easy one that's not even
politics were entitled to a second
amendment and he's trying to take the
second meaning that state is trying to
take the Democrats in that state the
Republicans are fighting it they're
trying to take that that second
amendment right that second amendment
right away to me that's Liberty that's
when I say liberate Virginia I would say
liberate Virginia when that kind of
thing happens there where does it all
stop so I think it's a very good analogy
go ahead sure I mean is this the right
time to kind of bring in a second
amendment issue I think when they talk
about taking your guns away and if you
notice at the beginning of this pandemic
there were more guns sold I think then
at almost any time in history because so
it's obviously a big issue and then you
have them working and signing documents
trying to take your your second
amendment away essentially so I do think
it's an appropriate time to bring it up
go ahead go ahead second we got a kind
of extraordinary slew of events from
adversaries North Korea Russia you know
China and Iran all pushing back on US
policy were toying with US military
forces what's your message was in these
countries who may be trying to we had a
very good relationship with Russia we
worked on the oil deal together
I was with on by telephone and king of
Saudi Arabia and the president of Russia
Vladimir Putin we worked out a deal on
oil there was a very important deal to
them and to us and to Saudi Arabia it
was in a deadlock you know what you
covered it very well actually Wall
Street Journal covered that very well I
worked with Putin and with the King on
that and President Putin was a total
gentleman and it was very important to
get that done and the king was great and
we actually had to bring in Mexico
because Mexico was alone hold out and
they showed great flexibility you know
the sewer no I think we're doing fine
yeah sure it's North Korea see they're
testing short-range missiles and you
know been doing it a long time I
received a nice note from him recently
it was a nice note I think we're doing
fine look
if I wasn't elected you would right now
be at war with North Korea okay
I'll tell you for your people that don't
understand the world and they don't
understand how life works if I wasn't
elected you would right now maybe the
war would be over hopefully with a
victory but if you remember when I first
came in we didn't have ammunition not a
good way to fight a war
President Obama left us no ammunition
okay and he left us virtually no medical
and ventilators he left us the cupboard
was dry right the cupboard was dry no I
think right now you'd be at war
essentially in some form be over it
would be raging with North Korea if I
weren't president and we're doing just
fine with North Korea just fine let's
see how it all ends up you know in the
meantime they said Oh
Trump's given up and they just said oh
really what's he giving up and they said
I don't know then they said he met oh I
meant I meant now I have a good
relationship with Kim jong-un that's not
a bad thing to have a good relationship
Obama wanted a relationship he wouldn't
meet with Obama wouldn't meet with him
okay I have a good relationship with him
we met at the line I stepped over the
line the first time anything like that
sir right so good it's just it's good
but when they say the stupid people I
call them stupid people or the haters
they say trips given up so much really
I've actually increased the sanctions
China's been very good on the border in
fact right now the border is stone
called close between China and North
Korea our relationship with China was
good until they did this once we found
out about this once we found out look we
just made a trade deal with China's
gonna have to buy 250 billion dollars a
year on our product 50 billion from the
farmers 40 to 50 billion from the
farmers the relationship was good when
we were signing that but then all of a
sudden you hear about this so it's a big
it's a big difference you know the
question was asked would you be angry at
China well the answer might very well be
a very resounding yes but it depends was
it a mistake that got out of control or
was it done deliberately okay it's a big
difference between those two in either
event they should have let us go in you
know we asked to go in very early
and they didn't want us and I think they
were embarrassed I think they knew it
was something bad I think they were
embarrassed but you know no I think
we're doing very well
so you said Russia you said China you
said North Korea Iran when I came in
Iran was a terror
we had 82 points of fighting we had 18
points of major confliction the first
week I said tell me about Iran sir we
have 18 points of confliction meaning
Yemen Syria or Iraq they were going into
Iraq all over the place they're much
different nation right now I stopped
that horrible deal horrible deal and
they want to talk except that Kerry
violated the Logan act he made the deal
and he doesn't want them and I could
deal because I would have made a deal in
my opinion except that John Kerry when
he who made the deal originally which
was a stupid deal to make him 150
billion dollars gave him 1.8 billion in
cash in green that would be more than
this room ten times with hundred-dollar
bills that you could fill up this room
ten times with hundred-dollar bills and
it's not that small room and I say he
violated the Logan Act I think it was a
major violation I think we would have
had a deal of it wasn't for John Kerry
but he doesn't want to be number one
embarrassed no but two he said let's
wait to left of the election made me
sleepy Joe Biden's gonna win and if
sleepy Joe Biden wins you'll own the
United States and China will own the
United States
China's paid us you know from The Wall
Street Journal hundreds of billions of
dollars is that right tariffs and we
gave a lot of that money small
percentage but a lot of money to the
farmers and it kept the farmers going
great right but hundreds will get we're
getting tens of billions of dollars in
tariffs and by the way for those of you
that say oh we're paying China devalued
their currency in order to pay these we
didn't pay China paid they don't like to
write that they also added money into
their system so they paid for that no I
think you have numerous countries
waiting to see whether or not sleepy Joe
wins because if sleepy Joe won they own
our country
they will take our country you know we
had go back two months we had by far and
the China was supposed to catch us you
know better than anybody Wall Street
Journal four years I've heard by 2019
China will catch us there's only one
problem Trump got elected in 2016 that
was a big difference and we were going
leaps and bounds above China and before
the problem with the plague right
China was having the worst year they've
had in 67 years that was before the
plague now they're getting really hurt
and so is everybody getting hurt I don't
want him to get hurt but they're all
getting hurt everybody's getting hurt
it's a horrible thing that's happened
but we had the greatest economy in the
world by far China isn't even close go
back two months and we're gonna keep it
that way
but when you mention Iran Iran is a much
different country than it was when I
first came in Iran was going to take
over the entire Middle East right now
they just want to survive they're having
protests every week
they loaded up with the plague which I
don't want I've offered to help them if
they want if they need ventilators which
they do I would send them ventilates we
have thousands of excess ventilators
coming in and and here we have a
stockpile of ventilators and we're
starting to send them so that hospitals
can fill up their stock by which they
should have New York had a chance to get
16,000 ventilators and they chose not to
do it and I understand that it's a hard
decision for a thing that may or may not
happen I fully understand that I'm not
even complaining about that I'm only
saying this Iran was a terror when I
came into office right now they don't
want to mess around with us they don't
want to mess around with us two things
North Korea same sanctions we've always
had except more we haven't given
anything I think you'll hopefully take
that back to the Wall Street Journal
because they really don't understand it
they really don't and with with Iran I
mean that's a different country right
now and they want to make a deal the
only reason that they don't they're
being shamed in because the guy that
gave them the sweetheart didn't want to
met with him many times he should have
never met with him and in my opinion
he's shown him don't we
maybe Trump will lose and then you can
negotiate with a patsy with a weak guy
and you'll take over the between you and
Russia
nobody's been tougher on Putin he knows
it better than anybody nobody been
tougher on Putin than me look at the
sanctions look at what I did with their
pipeline going into Europe nobody even
knew about it I exposed it now everybody
talks about it I think it's a terrible
thing for Germany to do but at the same
time I have a very good relationship
with Putin and I was able to get I was
able to make a deal with Russia and
Saudi Arabia and OPEC plus they call it
OPEC plus that's going to save us Texas
North Dakota Oklahoma other states
energy states going to save us hundreds
of thousands of jobs and in fact your
paper wrote an incredible editorial for
a change the Trump made a great deal for
our country that was a nice thing I was
shocked to see it coming out of the Wall
Street Journal thank you all very much
Andy president Trump on repenting on his
is rather that he's been having with the
the various governors and also
suggesting that he might want to kind of
take it out on China if there's some
suggestion that China did all this
knowingly yeah I mean look president
Trump at the moment is not holding any
of his by now-infamous rallies across
the country I think he's seeing these
press conferences as a replacement for
that I mean that last 15 minutes of
back-and-forth between him and reporters
was really him rambling about all sorts
of things and not really addressing
what's going on with the coronavirus so
he's using this platform I think to
campaign towards the presidential
election in November it's pretty clear
there's no evidence of what happened in
in China had this virus where it came
from what its origins were what they may
or may not be so he was just riffing at
this point but taking full advantage I
think of the fact that you know the
viewing figures for these press
conferences have been pretty highs even
boasted in the past that he's beaten
some reality shows on TV here in the
United States but he wasn't very focused
on what's going on in this country
obviously we're facing this situation
now where there is a phased reopening in
the country
there are protests going on were at a
critical juncture it's clear he also
made it very clear in previous press
conferences that it was the governor's
that have to make these decisions and
yet he's undermining them essentially by
tweeting out that various states should
be liberated throwing in as well in
Virginia and attacking the Democratic
governor there about gun rights things
that aren't really related to what's
going on the crisis that this country is
now facing because some of these states
like New York and here in Florida where
the corona virus has not expected to
peak for another few weeks this is a
really important situation for everybody
in this nation and he's up there really
politicizing the whole thing and that's
we're seeing that come across the
country because his tweets talking about
various states Minnesota Michigan and
Virginia needing to liberate he was
tying that in with gun rights when it
was clear what he's saying is those
right-wing protesters are on the streets
in those states that should continue
with their protest and they've spread
far beyond those three states they're
going on all over the country including
here in Florida we've had protesters in
Orlando so at one point he's saying look
the federal government will back up the
governor's but this is ultimately your
choice and on the other hand he's
tweeting out support for these people in
maggot hats and carrying ar-15 rifles
saying yeah go ahead make your voices
heard you're being treated roughly so
you know as per usual in these press
conferences it was rambling at times but
not really laser focused on the real
issue that this entire country is now
facing with more than 37,000 people who
have died from covert 19 and Andy he did
mention that Texas and Vermont would be
allowing certain businesses to reopen on
Monday and the Montana would be with
lifting restrictions on Friday will that
add to that to the pressure to find ways
of reopening the economy I mean there is
a real pressure there's no question 22
million people without jobs you heard
the president talking about the mental
and physical effects of those people
being out of work and staying in shelter
place orders it's a delicate balance
there's no question people want to get
the economy started again people want to
get back to their jobs but remember
under the president's own plan these
states and these counties because it's
county by county need to see a 14 day
decline in kovat 19 coronavirus cases
that's the Monday that the government
set out for these governors to make
their decisions by it's supposed to be
science-based but there is no question
there is now something of an ideological
struggle here between conservatives who
say look the cure is worse than a
disease we need to get the economy
restarted the biggest economy in the
world but then there are other people
saying look we have to look at the facts
and figures we have to look at who this
is affecting particularly people with
pre-existing conditions and really do
this very very carefully ultimately
those decisions will come from each
state's individual governors and places
like Montana which is sparsely populated
only a million people in that entire
state it's one of the biggest in the
country they may well be able to enter
phase one today or tomorrow or the next
few days ahead but for places like New
York it's a very very different picture
at the moment and a Galago loving me I'm
Miami thank you very much indeed